how's it going Rasmus Peter Pan welcome
to text and drive
wait I can't be right alright well let's
play it anyway click and drag to steer
okay whoa
click to open your phone alright alright
where are me hit the button are you
serious be safe
um I am here I'm gonna go there I'm on
the bridge awesome
are you sure you should be texting me
yes don't you know who I am but
it's me it's the least safe bridge in
the world am i texting and driving on
the least safe bridge of the world what
is dang it horse-racing integer dang it
I'm a strong 50 peasant woman what is
this what is 98.3 w RBS uh-huh give us
your money yeah your money ok what is
happening money so donate your money
today donating is as easy as giving us
your money
sometimes your company will give us
their money when fantastic everybody so
give us your money today ok your money
will go towards keeping this station
running so we can ask for your money
again at a later time how do you give us
your money why don't you check out our
Kickstarter to invest in better ways to
have you give us your money thank you
again for giving your money to 98.3 w
RBS I think I think I will not give him
my money alright who don't need no
guardrails just sliding this intro that
I told you so column yes I agree
yes I agree don't even get me started on
the children by the way my video game
kicks are planted Oh awesome which one
the tactical RPG too close for comfort
not the beer one run mageddon not to
parkour one I didn't say anything it's
kind of awkward but Brett shooter
barrier oh my god oh no you're
doing yeah I think it was bad in closet
ah
like ol time god damn it get off my turf
like old times
what what what do you mean old times
was I mean we both stopped doing this
for a good reason
sorry boo I can't believe this
I made pie and it's gonna get braked I
thought you didn't bake pie did this
time I did this time anyway forget it
I'm just gonna punch him into space
that's what you do when you really hate
someone
oh god I'm always falling out the bridge
and gotta be careful here that time for
his theatrics
sure Lowell what the hell does that mean
fight mode okay then alright alright
then alright I am alright alright two
special things oh oh
so worth playing through this what the
is happening oh god I'm gonna get
that set him set of a I'm gonna
kill that god damn it I
baked pies steer by oh yeah I got a
steer still got a charge my let my
I don't even know what I'm charging oh
my god
fantastic it's charging 49%
ow Plus are there yes I got a
charging up late you
break brofist y'all goodbye touch to it
ah dissolution Team Rocket finger bag
yet in the end final score punch power
so I got 31 texts 91 cars and 3 charges
left and 73% punch power the end by is I
love indie games are so weird I
thought this would be a game about don't
text and drive but it became so much
more so much deeper so thank you whoever
made it go ahead and ever like if you
watching hits sky Cumbre today if you
want to post your score I'll leave a
link to this in description and you can
try it out yourself and I'll see you
tomorrow